[Music]
nestled in the countryside this baroque
palace was only recently returned to its
former glory
known as a favorite of the empress
elizabeth of austria the queen of
hungary this is one palace truly built
for a royal family
but today it's open to visitors from
everywhere
this great big story was made possible
by
budapest
spice of europe
[Music]
considered hungary's answer to the
palace of versailles this masterpiece of
baroque architecture has everything
you'd want in a palace
the royal palace of godula was completed
in 1748 and was given as a wedding gift
to the new queen and king of hungary
the palace has a double u-shape and is
surrounded by an enormous park
[Music]
the ceremonial hall forms the center of
the palace's symmetrical plan
at the far end of the castle is a church
renovated in 1749.
a baroque theater hosted productions for
hungary's aristocracy
many of the mechanisms for changing
scenery still work today
in 1867 the hungarian parliament
purchased the palace and offered the
castle as a coronation gift to franz
joseph king of hungary and emperor of
austria
empress elizabeth of austria the queen
of hungary known more colloquially as
cece was particularly fond of the palace
of godullah and bathed the walls in her
favorite color violet blue
cece played a vital role balancing power
between austria and hungary
she loved hungary and its people and
devoted herself to learning the
hungarian language
though the connected rooms didn't offer
much in terms of privacy they were a
marked improvement from the busy
viennese royal court
the palace features walls and ceilings
decorated in a classical baroque style
the palace garden features tree-lined
avenues and a diverse collection of
beautiful flowers and plant life
both inside and out the palace of
godella is truly fit for a queen
[Music]